my colleague from the nfl media group as
well
as uh the co-host with daniel jeremiah
of this move the sticks podcast bucky
brooks back here on the rich eisen show
how you been bucky
i'm good rich how's everything better
for talking to you
uh we spoke to kyle pitts earlier this
week my god
uh i i loved him and then the next day
we had um
coach david shaw on and you know you
know david and
you know he doesn't there's two things
that kind of like stir
you know stir up the the hornet's nest
with him one is when
like a pet peeve of his gets broken uh
and then
two is when somebody's supremely
talented comes along he he could not
have been more
um excited to talk about him you called
kyle a
gold jacket talon
what do you think about kyle pitts that
made you say that
bucky i mean he's a really talented
player and i think
rich when we talk about top five players
we have to view them in that like can
you envision them
being a gold jacket player one day
meaning that they're going to be
one of the best players in their
position top two three or four
in the position within two to three
years and when you look at calculus
coming out of florida he has a unique
combination of size speed athleticism
he's a natural path catcher
he runs routes like a wide receiver yet
he's in an nba powerful
body and so you just think about how
difficult
that could be as a match-up uh you just
look at travis kelsey and dan waller and
some of those players on the outside
that have succeeded at the position for
lockdown
and if he's between vision calculus
being a guy that is next in line
do you think atlanta should just say you
know what
matt ryan's got two years left uh of a
contract that we're just not gonna get
out of it's insane to get out of it
it's very expensive to try and get out
of it we're not gonna get out of it
so let's get as much out of him as we
possibly can and add pits to
um calvin ridley and julio jones and go
to work
or do you think that their choice of
quarterback is going to be
too difficult for them to pass up and
try and set things up for when ryan is
done
i think it's a decision that we'll know
who's actually running the show
um between arthur smith and terry fonda
the general manager typically thinks
long-term thinks about the quarterback
thinks about how we can set the
franchise up to have a bridge
into the next decade the head coach
typically thinks about right now
um normally a right now situation would
be cal pits
with maddie ice julio jones kevin ridley
let's go play offense score points and
should figure out if we need dean peace
to slow down or create a defense
um that can play good enough for us to
win games and so it's really a
challenging decision for the atlanta
falcons because matt mattis is on the
hook for
at least the next year is just looking
at the dead cap situation and so it's
just one of those things where
we'll determine um who's actually
running the show in the winter
so what do you think they should do uh
you know i go back and forth uh because
there's a part of me that says
hey give me a quarterback because i
think this is a very special quarterback
class
but then also know if you get a middle
to field play maker um
and goods to go with uh peyton hurst
and the weapons that we talked about on
the outside i mean maddie ice can
go back to playing at a high level
particularly if office smith deals a
running game and they go play action
they do something
to ryan training with it so i can see
them going for the right now
trying to win games immediately and then
just worry about the quarterback when
you have to worry about a quarterback
down the road who do you think would
trade up for pitts
just because you'd call them again gold
jacket possibility
somebody sees what atlanta's thinking of
right now
but also knows that you know they could
maybe give atlanta a shot at the player
that they
don't want to take it for and and get
terry fontenot some more picks
who do you think could be that team um
you know i don't know like it's tough
like because jerry jones had a
conversation about
uh calpets and what he would do with
their athens uh you have other teams
that would certainly consider him i mean
the miami dolphins air team they can use
another
guy in the middle of the field to create
match-up problems
and so it's one of those things where
there's so many so many so many things
out there in terms of
the unknowns because the insurance is
with the quarterback that it's hard to
necessarily
take a team with them but i definitely
could see a team very very interested in
the playmaker because he is a unique
difference maker at the position
bucky brooks here in the rich eisen show
who do you think the niners traded all
the way up to go get uh justin field's a
tray lance
i think the conversation about mac jones
is just conversation
um i think when you're kyle shanahan and
you move up you move up to get a
remarkable talent
and so that talent to me needs to be
someone who can not only do the things
that you want to do on the script
but off the script because at the end of
the day what you're doing is you need to
compare your quarterback to the other
quarterbacks in the division
and if we're being honest rich the nfc
west has russell wilson colin murray and
matthew stafford
in any scenario do we view mac jones as
being a player that can be better than
any of those guys in the next two to
three years because if we don't then we
should make a move for him
but when we think about the
extraordinary talents of the two others
that are mentioned
we can see how their athleticism and
combination of arm talent
could give them an opportunity to
succeed and surpass some of those guys
in division
i think it has to be one of those two
other guys and i believe mac jones is
just a small screen no kidding
so what tell me about lance a little bit
because we really haven't spoken a lot
about him
since we you know first blush after the
trade
the general sense in so many parts was
this is definitely for mac jones and now
we're hearing
more fields and now we're gonna see
pro day 2.0 for trey lance as well what
about this young man
intrigues you bucky um
going all the way back to 2019 when you
watch them 28 touchdowns no
interceptions 2700 pat
senoras over 1100 rushing yards unique
playmaker with his size this is a guy
that was recruited
offered by big ten schools to play
outside linebacker safety to speak to
his
athleticism when you watch him play and
going back to 2019 you see him playing a
system that is multiple
and varied that has a lot of nfl
concepts in it
lay it with some college stuff if you
think about the players that have come
out of there carson lynch and eastern
state
respectively they handled a lot of this
stuff at the line of scrimmage that you
typically ask nfl quarterbacks to do
and so trey lance has all of that and so
he's a unique combination of the
athleticism and physical talent that you
want with the iq
and the upside that you also desire and
so as we think about the josh allen's of
the world
we think about the lamar jacksons of the
world man
if you can get a guy that has that extra
stuff it just allows you to do so much
when it comes to adding clay to the
playbook and game plan
and his ability to erase some of your
mistakes
huh so that would be tough for atlanta
to pass up right
if justin fields goes three that'd be
tough for atlanta to pass up would you
just describe to me because
arthur smith what he did with tannehill
i mean tanil was
as dangerous running it sometimes the
number of times will be like okay here
comes derek henry inside the five but it
would be tannehill takes it around the
end and take a
big hit i might add um that's kind of
what arthur smith would like to do
wouldn't you think yeah now i think trey
lance makes a lot of sense in atlanta
because what you're talking about with
matt
matty ice is you talking about two
additional years uh
the cap would say that you probably
can't move on from him until after 2022.
and so if we're talking about trey that
who's gonna enter in the league with 17
starts even though that's the same
number starts as mack
jones um it would give him two years
to develop to learn the game to sit and
kind of
get ready for the nfl game as a starter
we saw
it happen in one year for pat mahomes
maybe arthur smith uses a page out of
andy reed's playbook to get this
franchise up and going
so win now with matt ryan and then win
later
with trey lance that could be a foreign
so you
you don't buy it's like a the mac jones
is
the number three overall pick that's a
banana in the tailpipe
essentially right now for you
in my mind in my mind i i would just say
this like i think scouting comes down to
like
things being very very simple at any
time when you look at alabama did you
feel like mac jones was the best player
on the field
uh in the game like if you didn't
necessarily feel that way then you
shouldn't view him as one of the best
players
in all the football particularly in the
nfl draft look he's a really good player
he's a great distributor
but i think he's limited and i know
people like to make the comparisons
like hey look at what drew brees has
been able to do look at tom brady
but we're also talking about two
quarterbacks who have 20 years of
experience
playing the position in the national
football league i would challenge
anybody to show me
who is the young quarterback that plays
like them that is currently having
success in the league
and we can name one all the guys that
are young and dynamic and doing it
from justin herbert to josh allen to pat
mahomes and
sean watson and all those other guys
they have an extra element to their game
that allows them to shine and unless
look i i liken it to the avengers
um i believe that mac jones is iron man
everything around him is the suit and
the suit allows him to be a superhero
he doesn't have those special qualities
that any of the top four
have lawrence zach wilson trey land
justin fields in whatever order
all of those guys physically have super
hero powers
he does so what are what are the other
guys super powers then
what about that okay so we talked about
trevor lawrence in his
um supervisors it would be his
athleticism his arm talent
his leadership ability the fact that he
is being competitive and played at a
super high level
throughout when we talk about zach
wilson is his arm talent is spectacular
to go with his
athleticism his off platform throwing
ability
look his next level you can make the
comparison to aaron rodgers when you
watch him play
we talk about justin fields justin
fields is a five-star talent
we talked about the big time passing
ability to go with a guy who has four
four speed
who has played at a big stage displayed
the toughness against clemson where we
see him
dominate the game and be the best player
on the field and then trey lance we can
talk about the level of competition
but just in terms of a raw athlete
height weight speed on talent
he has collective super powers and mac
jones
what would we say about mac jones a all
the
adjectives have been like hey he's smart
he throws a touch timing in anticipation
but it's never about the physical
prowess we don't talk about hey he has
one of the strongest arms
or any of those things and so to me
there's a market difference between
those other guys and that child so where
does mac jones not get past
fill in that blank mac jones does not
get past fill in the blank
draft night i mean look he's going to go
in the first round
um i can tell you like i wonder like
people talk about
new england but my thing with new
england would be okay if you go all in
with
cam like what kind of offense are you
going to create now with
the things that you're doing and magic
like so maybe new england at 15
um maybe somewhere down in the bottom of
the first round because you have a
handful of teams that
need a young quarterback to build around
but i really think it's a mystery i
think the love
for him i think a lot of it has been
manufactured because a lot of
us are people on outside want to be
right on draft night
but i don't know if he's really viewed
like that
in the league by everybody ah last one
for you bucky do you think the niners
made the trade fully aware of who they
wanted and they're just grinding tape
to make sure right now what do you think
no i think they're i think they're aware
of a handful of quarterbacks that they
wanted to get in that conversation
uh at the time you didn't know what um
the jets were going to do
completely and so when you make that
move up to three that means you had to
be comfortable with
three of the quarterbacks after trouble
arms because you never know how that's
going to shape like hey what if
to just pull the end running justin
fields again that means you have to be
comfortable with zach wilson or
trey lance or whatever so i think they
were comfortable with any of
the three after trev alarm and now
they're just trying to sort out which
one do they really
believe is the town that can take their
offense to the next level because
remember this is what shanahan wants he
doesn't want to be the same
he doesn't want to be mediocre he won't
next level otherwise you don't make
that move so the player that they select
has to be somebody that he believes
our next level and i kind of leave you
with this remember
he tried to move off a little bit of
jimmy garoppolo when he talked up cj
beathard and nick muller
i would say that those guys in terms of
how they play
are more in line with mac jones than the
other guy
and so i think that is something to
consider
especially when he was on the field in
the super bowl and he lost to patrick
mahomes
and when you think about how the
shanahan and the disciples
have made moves at quarterback this
offseason after watching one of their
guys
matt lafleur have so much fun calling up
plays for aaron rodgers
i can't believe that they're trying to
get a pedestrian quarterback
to be their quarterback when they're
trying to take this offense to the next
level
bucky brooks great uh to have you on as
always
thank you and let's chat down the line
and uh i will see you
soon sir appreciate it thank you check
out bucky brooks with
daniel jeremiah on the move the sticks
podcast on
nfl network hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here